hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in addition to
the virtues and vices concerned with
things like courage temperance justice
ambition like great solace or bright
ambition generosity and magnificence
with respect to wealth or other
resources and then finally a good temper
with respect to the emotion of anger
Aristotle discusses a number of
different virtues that are concerned
primarily with our social existence he a
little bit of background he says that
that man is a political animal that is
human being is an animal the polis
Society yeah you can think of that in
terms of you know broad scale political
things but it really means in some
respect face-to-face interactions and
this also extends to the household which
has connect
with that and then all these
intermediate things between the
political society as a whole the
household friendships all these
intermediate things we have to deal with
each other as human beings and part of
human nature is actually concerned with
things like humour and so Aristotle
talks about virtues and vices that are
concerned with joking amusements
entertainment consultation there's
various ways in which we could translate
the terms that he's using for this and
what is he concerned with ads with all
the other virtues and vices there is a
mean a middle position where you have a
number of of Rights finding the right
balance of things and then there's an
excess and then there is a deficiency
and the excess of the inefficiencies are
what we call vices so with respect to
humor with respect to joking around
which by the way for aerosols are the
thing that goes both ways and it has to
do with how we act towards others
whether we make jokes whether we make
fun of that whether we pick on them
what kind of humor were involved with
when we do it how far we push it it also
has to do with what we're willing to
take in what we're going to accept what
we enjoy and what we turn a lot from so
what's fair with the the meat he says
good humor or wit it observes certain
limits in some respects the mean is
closer to the access because the
deficiency is not to enjoy
humor and all or to be humorless to be
boorish as our Oxford translators tend
to render this and we don't have a lot
of good words for this that I can I can
think of you know when it comes to the
excess replace another translation is
vulgar vulgarity Jackie a sickness
jackass where would be a perfectly good
way of translating it as well coming
back to the mean good even with means
that you do enjoy joking around
conversation other people engaging in
witticisms and it's sort of an ability
to appreciate what I would be blog
bringing and then to contribute your own
Aristotle actually a me Damien ethics
where he he actually talked quite a bit
about this he says wittiness is a middle
state that witty man is between the
borscht and burst if man and a buffoon
just isn't the matter of food the
squeamish man differs from the
omnivorous so he's got a culinary
metaphor this is the squeamish person
the finicky eater the one who really has
to subsist on this diet or that guy and
I can't take it a lot of stuff this is
the person who anything the omnivore and
you know in our contemporary culture
that that would go pretty far when then
so he says the squeamish man differs
from the I'm neveress and that the
former takes nothing or little and that
reluctantly to the latter
everything rattling the board stands in
a relation of auger manner buffoon the
former takes no joke it's something
difficult to the latter accepts
everything and with pleasure
neither course is right - he says one
should allow some things and not others
so there are certain limits there's
certain standards good taste or decorum
beyond which a person doesn't go if they
actually have a good humor or there's
certain boundaries now if someone
doesn't spell this out very clearly but
you know we could apply a lot of the
other rights you know like time right
reason right person - to this as well
there's no reason why they can't apply
all those - every one of the virtues and
vices yeah and so what Aristotle says is
that this person is going to remain
within certain certain boundaries
they're not going to joke all the time
they wouldn't for example tell jokes at
a funeral although they might at the the
wake if it's an Irish wake you know
everybody's enjoying themselves there's
an adaptability to good humor so a cage
when should you joke when shouldn't you
joke what kind of jokes are allowed to
be told in this situation in that
situation who do you joke about what
sort of things do you joke about or what
sort of things do you point out what
kind of jokes do you tell and then you
know you can also have what reason why
are you joking is it to try to actually
get pleasure is it to tease the other
person to be mean-spirited is it to try
to put people in their place
Aristotle doesn't talk about this but
one of the other vices
are the people who use humor as a weapon
against other people and I don't mean
you know like political satirist in that
case you know that's more like these
Ravinder I'm talking about people in
personal life boring workplaces or I
think there's professors who do this as
well with students who do mean people
who belittle them by using something
that looks a lot like human but really
isn't humour and this comes to show us
the dividing lines between the XS and
the mean that has to do with causing
pain aerosol was very clear about this
he says can we define proper raillery
raillery is when you're like poking at
somebody joking with them but it's
saying that it's Jets are never
unbecoming to gentlemen and the people
who are Agathon and how long they have
the right sort of you know moral values
or that it avoids giving pain or indeed
actually gives pleasure to its objects
this is or isn't impossible to define
something so so Lucifer tastes differ as
to what is offensive and what is amusing
he says whatever rule we laid down the
same will apply to other things a man
should allow to be said to and can we
figure this out and we can come up with
sort of rough rules sometimes we have to
you know lay these rules down because
somebody goes too far we say that that
really is causing pain sometimes we
requires an experience with respect to
this but here's what is going out of the
mean this is a person who is
well enough to others to not cause them
pain bye-bye joking with them they were
making fun of them
yeah actually cause them some degree of
pleasure so think of if you've ever had
this experience introducing somebody at
a banquet or a conference you know a
speaker and you know poking some gentle
fun at them it actually makes them feel
good you can make fun of people who are
rich and are not you know insecure about
their wealth by talking about them being
cheap or things like that you know you
can tribute things to people provided
they're not going to take it too
personally and get upset about it so you
wouldn't for example it makes make fun
of somebody who is sensitive about the
baldness by talking about their their
big bald spot or why they shave your
head if somebody has a they're sensitive
about then you wouldn't focus on that if
somebody is particularly ugly you might
not make fun of you know it's
interesting if you look at roast roasts
are where you would think it's all
buffoonery and those go to show us that
there is a bit of situation ality to it
that you know some things can go and
roast and certainly wouldn't go in a
awards banquet or at the family
Thanksgiving dinner or you know things
along those lines
even at roast you could say well that
person really
too far they were being spirited they
were just there to get a laugh no matter
what and then there's always you look at
them in your life and that person may
actually has good taste there that are
able to take a joke and give a joke back
and what they're saying it may be kind
of biting but it's not like devastating
now over on this end this is not to say
that people who are you know joking all
the time are necessarily telling jokes
that that hurt people as a matter of
fact that could be just a very small
portion of the time well what's going on
is that they don't observe limits yeah
they're being drawn by different desires
than the person who has good taste the
person who has been taste wants to enjoy
conviviality with other people they want
to enjoy literally that sort of being
lively together that that sense of
enjoyment of you know bubbling passion
sparkling wit that sort of thing this
person needs to joke all the time and
that's a problem because they will
inevitably go through far there is you
know a lot of pieces are something
lacking in their life when they need to
constantly fill things in with humor you
know think about the person for example
in our culture who is always quoting the
funny movie lines until they quit being
funny and they use them over and over
again in situations now that's not
really causing pain in the sense of like
hurting people's feelings instead it's
like an hinging amount of people in like
come on that's enough just knock it away
you know I've heard that line 20 times
it's no longer funny these are the
people who need attention the attention
that humor gives and they also you know
some of them may be people who cannot
settle down and be serious about things
about which one actually ought to be
serious now if we swing to the other
extreme we have this boorishness
stick-in-the-mud kind of people the
people that are not good to jump around
with they tend not to make jokes
themselves they may not actually
understand jokes if it's really really
far to the extreme they don't enjoy
humor and others oftentimes they take
offense at other people's attempts to to
introduce jokes so you can see perfect
bottom of you something like this is
something like this put together this
person is going to drive this person
guts and this person is also been
driving this person once they cause pain
to other people as well in part because
if you make a joke to them if you're
just trying to like you know have fun
make friends carry on
light conversation they can't do it so
these are the people that need to be
serious all the time Saturday I've
actually had this kid called Debbie
Downer it's interesting because we've
learned a lot about comedy and humor
from comedians and
people who are actually engaged and that
makes perfect sense because they
actually reflect on that Debbie Downer
would always have something serious and
sad to say after everybody said anything
you know they might talk about their cat
and she say her cat died last week
now does that cause pain in the sense of
like you know tearing somebody down or
you know reawakening old painful
memories probably not but it does cause
a pain or discomfort or social what
would we call it you know it's the
opposite of when things are are going
well socially and social friction let's
call it awkwardness that's the word
awkwardness
people like this tend to be rather
awkward so this is going to be the
meaning that we want to be aiming for
yeah or subtle does he have a few other
things to say about it he says we want
to rely on the person who actually has
good judgment when it comes to this as
the standard this isn't in some respects
a virtue that's harder to pin down than
say justice or temperance or even
courage it's a little bit more malleable
a little bit
founder but it is something that's a
very important part of our our what when
I'm close by actually mentioning
something the medievals would would
sometimes jokingly define man or human
being as the visible hand meaning the
animal that laughs it is that what what
about parents with my hyenas hyenas are
actually laughing in the same sense that
we are they don't enjoy humor parrots
are just parroting things back some
higher animals do seem to mess with each
other it's good enjoy that and to engage
in play and do they actually like play
jokes on each other
not so much we have an entire sort of
universe of that particularly now that
we have the internet and you can
generate your own beings you can just
type in you know humor and all sorts of
websites will come off I actually try to
make sure no matter how much work I'm
actually doing or walk down in to do
something each day that will involve
some sort of humor could be reading even
wasps already because it's that dry by
tanks are diving with could be going on
college humor and watching a skit could
be going on cracked and reading one of
their ten most lists or something like
that and I think that's a very important
part of life I think it's very important
for helping to Garris probably would
agree so this is a mean that we want to